nice Lillard no heckling no problem
we're not in Orlando he's got business
to take care of
Stauskas a little bit of daylight to his
liking swings it outside of Damian
he'll dribble into a three-shot oh
you're not taking the ball out of the
net we're pushing the ball up quicker to
the jump stop magic by eight Damian
swerves off a nerd screen it drops down
another three it might have to beat at
court Damian because we two kids playing
several feet off to go back to this type
of action right here we're open to make
you beg for my my media report outside
here is Damian Lillard you know each
other especially Evan Turner saying we
have to talk louder to each other coach
saying everything that is happening
right now because
communication we have to talk we have to
anticipate the good defensive play as a
time before word as he's dropped back
into coverage knows where that ball is
going can try to play hero ball and just
make a one-on-one mo but sees how far
who to pitch is all can help
and Damien
is locked in we stats wants the
favorable two-to-one Lillard off the
screen dribbling into a three feeling it
fly and catching the roll 10 threes for
Lillard on 10 of 12 shooting
[Applause]
[Music]